boa tarde turma tudo bem
é um prazer estar aqui com vocês vou
contar um pouquinho da minha história a
doutor agora um pouco da minha
experiência só o empreendedor viciado
já estou na minha segunda história de
empreendedorismo e eu queria contar um
pouco uma mistura do que eu fiz do que é
o nosso negócio e se eu puder ajudar a
turma que está aqui tomar uma decisão
sobre empreender ou não entender o
porquê empreender eu espero ter um
impacto positivo pra turma aqui e esse
meu primeiro slide eu falo qual é o seu
sonho o nosso sonho
agora nós nós enxergamos um mercado
tinha uma forma macro você tem um setor
público é bastante defasado onde o
atendimento às pessoas não é um
atendimento de qualidade e nós queríamos
trazer acesso para essa turma nós
queremos trazer eficiência para o
sistema tendo o sistema público quanto o
sistema privado essa é a nossa a nossa
visão do negócio
e aí você tem um no processo de
empreender se tem vários vários momentos
né
você olha tem um empreendedor que vai
fazer uma coisa por necessidade
aliás hoje eu tive um exemplo fantástico
vindo pra cá em que eu estava dirigindo
na bandeirantes e tinha um sinal de
drive-through embaixo de uma ponte onde
está tendo uma uma construção e
simplesmente um cara botou uma botão uma
barraquinha lá dois reais e drive
through e café da manhã e se esse é o
clássico empreendedor de necessidade
achei aquilo absolutamente fantástico
mas nós lá no no doutor agora a gente
queria ter um impacto na vida das
pessoas no nosso negócio nosso modelo de
negócio tem um pouco a ver com o negócio
dos palestrantes antes de mim que é
trazer eficiência do sistema
neste processo de construção do racional
porque é o doutor agora porque o nosso
modelo era um modelo que faria sentido
porque nós somos uma uma clínica de
atendimento de baixa complexidade e
existia uma oportunidade ali eu sempre
uso essa frase é que a oportunidade vem
pra pra quem está preparado porque a
oportunidade ela vai passando na frente
de um monte de pessoas e não
necessariamente todas as pessoas têm a
capacidade de pegar aquela oportunidade
fala olha isso aqui faz sentido eu vou
perseguir esse assunto né então um
processo de construção do nosso negócio
nós pensamos olha tem um atendimento de
baixa complexidade que a gente quer
fazer a entrega desse atendimento na
cadeia de atendimento primário de forma
mais eficiente com um foco restrito de
atendimento e com uma distribuição pela
cidade onde nós trouxéssemos acesso e aí
eu estou falando do ponto de vista de
conveniência e também do ponto de vista
de preço o que o pai eu voltei aqui
deixei pra frente e aqui falando da
nossa ideia é enxergando o mercado
brasileiro o mercado de são paulo e que
como nós entregaremos esse serviço de
forma mais eficiente aí nós olhamos
modelos fora do brasil como é que esse
negócio estava sendo entregue lá e tem
um modelo bastante consolidado que chama
é mina clinic dentro da cadeia de
farmácias da cvs e passamos ali um ano
estudando o modelo e vimos lá olha esses
caras estão fazendo isso de forma
restrita tem um escopo de atendimento
baixo mas eles impactam hoje 20 milhões
de pessoas nos estados unidos inteiro
economizar 1 bilhão de reais a um bilhão
de dólares no sistema de saúde
só que esse modelo trouxe acesso
nível por uma camada da população que
não tinha sorte e nesse processo de
entendimento de discussão da ideia é nós
não conseguimos entender por que que ele
se restringiam apenas aos atendimentos
de baixa complexidade
até que nós conseguimos chegar no
fundador desse modelo e quando nós
chegamos lá fomos num processo de e no
linkedin todo dia encontramos o telefone
do cara da residência dele e até o
momento que o cara não foi uma coisa de
maluco porque nós como semanas o que não
precisamos entender o negócio para ver
se era aplicável no brasil eo racional
desse negócio até que infelizmente acho
que minha mulher conseguiu o acesso
melhor que eu e o cara nos atendeu
mas de forma muito clara é que nós
entendemos esse negócio ele pegou o
atendimento primário ele foi pronto
socorros americanos foi em ambulatórios
americanos e olhou aquilo lá e pegou
quais são as doenças de baixa
complexidade e qual é o volume disso
olha 60% e quando eu falo doença de pé
condições de baixa complexidade são
consultas médicas literalmente consultas
médicas e esse cara olhou aquele número
e falou olha pegou um médico ele é um
empreendedor insere pegou um médico
falou conseguimos fazer tirar isso aqui
do ambiente um hospital ambulatório e
trazer para o ambiente de varejo trazer
perto das pessoas onde a gente entregue
um qualidade onde nós entregamos é preço
e conveniência e eles olharam aquele
modelo falou olha conseguimos tirar
então naquele momento naquele momento
nós entendemos que era um negócio
factível no brasil e fazia e fazia
bastante olhamos modelo aqui
as estatísticas do brasil e de fato 57%
dos atendimentos na pesquisa que nós
fizemos com data surgiu no setor privado
era o atendimento de baixa complexidade
então nós somos um órgão só que faz
sentido vamos trazer
e vamos botar o nosso modelo em ambiente
de varejo
vamos botar o nosso modelo em um lugar
onde tem passagem nós fomos a primeira
clínica abrir dentro do metrô então hoje
nós já temos três clínicas do metrô
e nesse processo
nós conseguimos validar o modelo é
conseguimos que as pessoas que estão
passando
saindo de de ambientes hospitalares que
não têm acesso
começando a entender o nosso negócio com
uma forma nova de entregar o atendimento
o atendimento primário no processo de
teste né
estou aqui no um pouco conseguindo nosso
caminho de de empreender o
empreendedorismo né ea gente foi
testando o negócio nós abrimos a nossa
primeira clínica foi nós abrimos na vila
olímpia ea tese de lá é porque a gente
estava na frente da estação do metrô e
nós capturaremos diferentes classes
sociais nós atenderemos é as classes
sociais de baixa renda que a maioria vem
a linha do metrô e e e trabalho na na
vila olímpia e nós também atenderemos o
público passante que é um público um
pouco de classe média ou até classe
média alta
e aí nós começamos a testar o nosso
modelo é o que o que a gente queria
mudar como como modelo estava sendo
entregue hoje como como as pessoas
entendiam que isso poderia ser entregue
de uma forma diferente e aí a gente
tirou do papel
né eu uso bastante essa essa frase
também que é uma idéia sem ela ser
executada ela não é nada
então no momento que nós botamos o nosso
o nosso negócio para uma popular e ativo
de trazer acesso à população na nossa
primeira clínica piloto nosso terceiro
cliente foi um cara davi lucca da vila
olímpica que conheceu o modelo
fora do brasil e esse era 11 sei lá o
cara entre os 10 mais ricos de são paulo
do brasil e entrou lá e aí a gente olhou
para a cara do outro falou caramba
fizemos alguma coisa errada porque a
gente está fazendo por um outro público
é o grande foco do nosso modelo e entrou
um cara aqui bilionário nosso é o que
está acontecendo
então a gente foi testando o nosso o
nosso modelo
fomos passando por por várias várias
vários testes de conceito e começamos a
entender que esse público de de baixa
renda eles ainda tinha uma um
preconceito do modelo tinha uma um de
entendimento de como é que esse negócio
funcionava e fomos entendendo né
andamos os os primeiros seis meses do
negócio na vila olímpia tivemos a esse
essa figura ilustre que passou pela
nossa clínica e aí a realidade do modelo
porque o que aconteceu antes de a gente
começar um processo de expansão hoje nós
já temos cinco clínicas já passaram por
lá algo entre 4 a 5 mil até r pacientes
e quando você olha a distribuição de cep
que nós temos na nossa clínica da vila
olímpica a gente começou a atender
literalmente a cidade de são paulo foi
aí que nós decidimos olha eu acho que
validou deu certo e vamos começar aí pra
outros pra outros ambientes então dá-lhe
nós fomos pra dentro do metrô santana
fomos pra jovane gronchi dentro de um de
uma rede supermercado e o negócio
começou a tomar forma
porque eu acho que o grande segredo do
nosso negócio é que o foco nas condições
de baixa complexidade com um modelo
muito simples tem uma consequência que a
conseqüência de preço ea segunda
derivada disso é o acesso
então nós permitimos o acesso a uma
população que literalmente não
tinha a este tipo de negócio é esse tipo
de cuidado e é a maior preocupação nossa
é dentro do dentro da companhia porque a
turma de renda de classe média e classe
média alta
eles já têm um nível de serviço não é
não é uma uma clínica bonita que vai
fazer a diferença mas sim um grau de
conveniência e nós nos preocupamos muito
com a turma de baixa renda e parte da
instrução que nós temos do nosso time é
de genuinamente literalmente cuidar
acolher essas pessoas porque elas estão
vindo do sus então quando é quando a
gente percebe quem são essas pessoas né
as outras clínicas que nós temos a gente
tem dentro da sé dentro do brás é então
você percebe quando essas pessoas estão
entrando e esse é o maior foco de
atenção é como é que a gente já como é
que a gente entrega um serviço com nível
de qualidade e e e que elas não de fato
ainda não tiveram essa experiência
porque muito nossas consultas lá custa
89 reais mas para pessoas de baixa renda
às vezes é 57 10% da renda deles então
de fato o investimento e parte do nosso
do nosso da nossa visão de negócio é
trazer essas pessoas para dentro engajar
elas com o nosso modelo de negócio e
fazer com que ele com que ele se
perpetue né
aqui a gente falando aqui do nosso do
nosso momento do doutor agora nós
passamos na fase de teste na fase de
captação de recursos
eu tive outra experiência no setor de
saúde que era eu participei da
construção de uma rede de hospitais e
com muita muita muita dificuldade das
pessoas acreditarem no teu negócio então
eu falo aqui para as pessoas que pensam
empreender que isso é um você precisa
ter isso em você no teu grupo e com as
pessoas
que fazem parte da tua visão do que você
quer mudar e aí o próximo passo desse
negócio é como é que lidar como é que
ele funciona como é que ele dá certo é
hoje nós como eu falei nós já atendemos
quase 5 mil pacientes nós temos cinco
clínicas
estamos tão abrindo mas o os milestones
que nós nos propusemos ao longo desse
caminho
alguns nós não atingimos né às vezes há
as premissas são agressivas demais você
tem uma visão mágica que as coisas vão
acontecer não necessariamente elas elas
acontecem mas nós nós conseguimos que
70% da nossa base dos pacientes têm uma
avaliação super positiva do nosso
negócio é o mais legal pra mim que sendo
um co fundador desse negócio é quando eu
pego e converso com o paciente e aí
literalmente o meu foco são os pacientes
de baixa renda
e aí você vê um paciente saindo de uma
de nossas clínicas nossa eu não
imaginava que era isso porque ele
colocou 10% da renda dele numa consulta
médica e então a nossa eu tenho e por
obrigação eu tenho que entregar um nível
de serviço muito mais alto pra ele
eles estão vindo nível de serviço muito
baixo então a satisfação é muito grande
então isso foi um passo foi um passo
importante nós começamos a ter esse tipo
de feedback dos nossos dos nossos
pacientes e andando nessa na viagem do
empreendedorismo né
essas pessoas têm essas visões de o que
elas vão fazer o que elas vão mudar que
mercado
elas vão mudar né nosso nosso caso a
gente está atingindo essa população
trazendo acesso qualidade e tenho a
consequência nós não somos uma
organização
sem fins lucrativos né a e aí eu uso
muito isso aqui porque eu já estou no
meu segundo jato número cinco do
história de empreendedorismo e nenhuma
dessas duas eu entrei com a motivação de
dinheiro porque eu conheço muita já
passei por muitas conversas de pessoas
não querem empreender porque eu quero
ficar rico porque eu quero fazer isso e
e não é esse o caminho acho que se tem
alguém aqui empreendendo imaginando que
esse é o caminho fácil e dinheiro é você
vai construir um modelo de negócio em
dois anos e vai ser extremo sucesso eu
acho que isso é uma falácia então pense
nisso se eu puder ter um impacto aqui
pra turma da da universidade é faça um
negócio faça ele muito bem feito
entregue à sua proposta de valor
genuinamente e pense que essa proposta
de valor e se o feedback positivo da
entrega do teu serviço do teu produto
vai fazer isso daqui mas não empreenda
por causa disso a grana consequência do
seu do seu produto e eu termino
apresentação com uma com uma frase do
nelson mandela que sempre parece
impossível
até quando isso é feito obrigado